something to peel off with eh the gentlemen wilders
eh if you become the largest fraction
eh after the election in this room
then you give that
the law
to take it iniciatively to see if you
1 cabinet can form
is my analysis correct so far for your wilders
yes I think I no longer play 1 quiz games
ok so if you keep it fine
if you ask me 5 questions there will be no answer
yes well calm dude
quiet dude i just ask 1 quiet question
yes i just give 1 quiet answer
oh yes you certainly think so
a pity hey good no no we will still be there
we'll still get there
well so look what i am
what i will try
is to help you 1 bit from that messiah
get rid of you in a complex way
look because you have
37 seats in this room
that gives you the right to take it iniciatively
and you are entitled to that
if you don't succeed
then you can also simply go into position
there is nothing undemocratic about that
if you don't succeed in people
willing to get
you as uh leader of the cabinet as prime minister
uh to appoint then there is nothing undemocratic about it
that is silly what you said about that
that's just that
in line with Dutch constitutional law
that open owl got in 7753 seats
he didn't get the inicative
2 other parties CDA and VVD for each other
took over and he entered the opposition
that is dutch constitutional law
and don't twist it now
get rid of that messiah complex
you have 1 large one verantwoordelijkheid
but
do not paint yourself as savior of the homeland
and he doesn't want to do it at all
as if you are the only one here
who come to Wil for the Dutch national interest
u uh
uh grew wilders with his 36 minions
everyone sitting here in the room
stands up for the national interest from his own
uh uh ideology
I would like to tell you that uh
and just be 1 adult police kiss
and stop complaining
that you do not allow the position of prime minister
there is for that
if this is the level of
interruptions from 1 future opposition leader
then uh
I still get it easily
we will see that
I can answer this with 2 fingers in my nose
yes well free
to get started
the Lord then l 77
don't forget the Lord than seventy-three
live in the hild and l
1973 the uh elections
Uhm and uh came Uhm as the winner
became minister
president and a little later
also called 1 form of extra-parlamentary cabinet
is called Uhm so there he was
and your outleader
1973 form of extra palamenteer
political leader became prime minister
a little earlier the Lord travels
negentienachtenveertig elections
it was not the winner but
party leader
in something that was seen in 1 form of extra palm tar
and became a minister
president so it's not that bad at all
also not in the form
that we choose now
and certainly not outside of that form
look at all the last uh cabinets
with uh Mr. Rutte at the head
you had it on the Rutte
the Lord ruttes must hold out
You won the elections
but French timberman or someone else becomes the prime minister
he had chased you out of the room
and that reads are under judge
whatever you think of the man
he had won the elections
so both historically and in the present
it is very normal
and actually also 1 unwritten
rule that may not always apply
You are right about that,
but usually it does apply
that the winner of the mistakes
from the largest party
if it doesn't go into the opposition
that he still has the first right to be prime minister
and I think so too
that I should have become that
and in the end that doesn't work
and I am responsible enough to say
then we will all stay in the room
and then we take care
that the Netherlands still gets 1 good governance
that is not only responsible
that is how it should be and you can learn something from it
thanks for the lesson mister wilders
I note that you can do it now
Formulates differently than you did on x
you call it now
not undemocratic if you do not become a prime minister
I think that's correct
because it is not undemocratic that you have none
becomes prime minister
and I would just hold that because uh
it can be done in all sorts of ways
that teaches dutch parlamentary history
and the fact that you
the biggest fraktie of today in this room
don't give you the right to it
uh premiership
and by the way Uhm
I also totally agree with the argument
from the Lord fur ball
you just become part of 1 majority cabinet
to which you will supply all 4 ministers
so you have just provided that clarity
thank you uh chairman
yes i was wondering how
Uhm how is the chemistry actually between the PVV
the VVD the bvb and new social contract
awesome